I'm gonna start by pointing out some of
the symbolism in this movie then at the
end I'll piece it all together and let
you know how the religious subplot ties
into the surface-level story about the
author and his wife let me start off by
saying that different audiences are
gonna have different interpretations of
this movie this is just my
interpretation so if your view on the
movie isn't the same as mine then screw
you idiot so with that all out of the
way I see this movie as a representation
of the Exodus long story short back in
the day the Israelites were enslaved by
the Pharaoh in Egypt there was a snood
named Moses God hits him up and says
he's gonna have to drop these plagues on
the Egyptians to force them to let his
people go there were 10 plagues and all
these events are the basis for the
Jewish holiday Passover each of these
ten plagues are represented in Darren
Aronofsky's film the first plague was
the plague of blood in the Exodus all of
the water in Egypt is turned into blood
in mother the two brothers barged into
the house and start arguing about their
fathers well this leads to a physical
fight resulting in death the living room
or in this case the dying room is
covered in a pool of blood and no matter
what Jennifer Lawrence does she can't
get the blood to fully go away much like
another horror movie that came out this
year the blood seeps down into the
cellar and follows this path along the
wall which shows us that it isn't just a
regular leak there is something of a
divine interference this part may or may
not be related but when the water in
Egypt was turned into blood the
Egyptians suffered from terrible thirst
when Ed Harris gets to the house
Jennifer Lawrence offers him some tea
she gets back from making it to find
that they've already broken into a flask
of the alcohol
not to mention Michelle Pfeiffer's crazy
obsession with making lemonade so this
could mirror the thirst of the Egyptians
the basement is the setting for the
appearance of several of the plagues I
also like the idea of the blood being
something that's literally sent from
above and in the Exodus the Egyptians
tried digging into the ground to find
water only to find more blood similar to
how Jennifer goes underground in the
basement and finds more blood there as
while it's also worth noting that Moses
makes the blood first appear by striking
the Nile River with a wooden staff and
the blood and mother appears after the
brother strikes his sibling with a
wooden chair the second plague is frogs
the Egyptians houses were invaded by
these swarms of frogs right after she
goes into the basement to follow the
blood there's this wall that she breaks
away and it leads her to a secret area
where she finds a frog living in her
basement it wasn't a swarm of frogs but
it's more of just a subtle reference
plus where there is one amphibian there
are usually more to be found
the only plague that I'm not entirely
sure about is the third one which is
lice / bugs it's likely that this plague
is represented somewhere in the movie
considering that the other nine are
accounted for but I wasn't really
looking out for it when I was watching
this for the first time if you have any
ideas about this one let me know in the
comments I'd love to fill in that
missing piece but anyway the fourth
plague is accounted for when Javier
Bardem offers to hold the wake for the
deceased son of Edie Harris the house is
overrun seemingly by tons of random
guests and these guests represents the
Horde of wild beasts in the exodus
passage the beasts are described as wild
animals that Rove all over the country
and destroy everything that they have
built our two main characters have spent
their marriage renovating this house
together and these people literally roam
in hordes to destroy what they have
built together the fifth plague involved
a disease that killed all of the
Egyptians livestock Jennifer and Javier
aren't shown to have any livestock but
there is a scene in the kitchen where
she sees a dying bee keel over and pass
away this is the most relevant modern
world example to disease livestock
beekeeping is an industry where colonies
are maintained by men in order to
collect and sell the natural products
that bee produces one that has been
threatened in recent years by a
mysterious disease killing up to 50
percent of beans in this case the bees
represent the livestock of the
beekeepers and the colony collapse
disorder is a modern day playing against
them the sixth plague was Boyle's which
manifests to be first night that Ed
Harris stays over at the house he gets
sick and Jennifer Lawrence hears him
coughing as she's trying to get to sleep
she gets up to see everything's alright
and finds her husband tending to him
he's coughing and vomiting over the toy
and he seems to be covered in painful
looking boils when she asked him about
it the next day he claims to be fine in
addition to that here's the actual quote
from the exodus passage take handfuls of
soot from a furnace and have Moses toss
it into the air in the presence of
Pharaoh it will become fine dust over
the whole land of Egypt and festering
boils will break out and animals
throughout the land the movie has a
strong emphasis on the furnace in the
basement at first I thought it was a
throwback to the refrigerator in
Aronofsky's mm film requiem for a dream
just because of the fact that it's a
large appliance that makes noises that
scare her and at that point in the film
it seemed like it was possibly a
hallucination however looking back on it
there may have been a deeper
significance later in the movie we
actually see the furnace soot stuff
being plastered on Javier Bardem
followers the seventh plague is a
thunderstorm of hail again this isn't
represented with a literal hailstorm but
rather a scaled-down representation this
comes up during the wake scene and
despite Jennifer Lawrence's constant
requests people keep sitting on her sink
countertop which has not yet been
reinforced eventually the counter snaps
the pipe breaks and storm of water
sprays up and begins flooding the house
creating complete chaos Jennifer
Lawrence even refers to the mess created
by these people as an apocalypse a
reference to the apocalyptic conditions
of the after mention hailstorm
and now not not that hailstorm moving
right along to plague AIDS we have the
locusts after the thunderstorm God's
message for Pharaoh was this if you
refused to let them go and we'll bring
locusts into your country tomorrow it
will cover the face of the ground so
that it cannot be seen they will devour
what little you have left after the hail
they will fill your house and those of
all your officials and all of the
Egyptians
I see the representation of the locusts
and mother-to-be the fans of Javier
Bardem they invade the house literally
to the points that the floor cannot be
seen they devour all of the food
including the meal that Jennifer
Lawrence had just prepared ripping the
house apart to get a piece of their
hero's life that situation continues to
devolve until there's a full-on war
taking place in the house complete with
soldiers and riot police it is at this
point that Jennifer Lawrence is
temporarily blinded she gets sprayed in
the face with pepper spray
enter plague number nine darkness and of
course all of this culminates with the
tenth and final plague death of the
firstborn Jennifer Lawrence finally
delivers her baby Javier Bardem gives it
to the people they're careless actions
lead to the baby's neck snapping now
that I've identified the ten plagues or
at least nine of the ten
I'll let the director Darren Aronofsky
explain the roles of the characters and
their relationships to the religious
figures using to tell the story of
humanity the stories of the Bible
so Edie and Michelle are the first man
and woman and these are the sons
probably been figure out who Xavier is
from that last shot so with all of that
in mind let's take a look back at the
scene in the study when Ed Harris first
sees the I'm just gonna call it the
shiny object he is captivated by it he
feels the need to hold it to touch it
but Xavier tells him that the shiny
object is very precious to him and
forbids him from touching it going so
far as to say no guests will be allowed
in the study while he's
in there the shiny object is our
metaphorical apple of Eden but Eden
Michelle being the Adam and Eve that
they are go in there anyways and break
it and then God is pretty upset and he
forever bans them from the Garden of
Eden by boarding it off with a hammer
and nails they retreat to their room and
the next time we see them they're doing
it next thing you know they have kids
who show up at the house Cain and Abel
Cain is the older brother thought to be
the originator of all things evil and
violence a shout out to him he slays his
younger brother Abel and the family
proceeds to grieve and it's during this
time that they turned to God slash
Javier Bardem who gives them a speech at
the wake that offers them hope this
leads to him gaining a huge following
and these people become his worshippers
he writes a holy scripture aka his book
however some of them are led astray in
worship of false idol which we see when
the people are worshiping a photo or his
possessions rather than the real thing
that's kind of where the ten plagues
thing comes in the Egyptians worshipped
the Pharaoh a false god while the Jews
worship their one and only God the
Jewish people escaped Egypt and are
promised the Holy Land of Israel by God
but they're also the Palestinians who
also claim the divine right to that land
so a huge fight breaks out which we see
in the movie starting as the followers
of Xavier arguing over who gets to be in
the house which eventually becomes who
gets his possessions and continues to
devolve into a full-blown war zone
representative of the ongoing Israeli
Palestine conflict finally Jennifer has
the baby and all of Javier's followers
are waiting outside to see the newborn
you could look at this as the birth of
Christianity with the baby being Jesus
and dying for the people's sins or you
could examine Jennifer's actions
sheltering the baby for many days and
nights asking Javier the Pharaoh the
false God to make those people go before
he holds the child and very similar to
Moses asking Pharaoh to let my people go
and also aligning with the Torah story
of the Israelites escaping from Egypt
and wandering the desert for forty years
to let the generation that was tainted
by Pharaoh die off so that a new your
generation could enter the promised land
the new iteration of the cycle could
represent a new beginning in that
promised land or it could represent the
opening of a new book the new testament
it all depends how you look at it and I
think that's the point as with real life
there are different people with
different beliefs and this is the cause
for different religions that's my
interpretation of the subtext but what
does that have to do with the surface
level story the one about a writer and
his wife trying to have a baby I think
Aronofsky is comparing our current
celebrity crazed culture to be worship
of false idols when Ed Harris gets to
the house he poses as a doctor who has
lost his way looking for a place to stay
Jennifer later finds a picture of her
husband in the man's bag from the about
Me section of one of his books the man
confesses to being a superfan who came
out just to see Xavier before he passes
away Xavier says that it's nice to have
someone who appreciates his writing to
which Jennifer responds I love your work
this creates the divide between someone
who loves him for who he is and someone
who worships the idea of him as a
celebrity persona ed become so
enthralled by his idol that he brings
his wife along to meet him after the
unfortunate passing of the man's son
Xavier offers hospitality and words of
wisdom in front of a large group of
people and his cult following grows
after releasing his next Scripture he
has fans waiting outside his house to
meet him and before long that turns into
breaking into his house people fighting
over him tossing all of their morals for
a chance to meet him Aronofsky is
commenting and how modern obsession with
celebrities has become like a religious
craze people worship these celebrities
and look at the damage that it causes as
far as I noticed not one of the
characters in the movie is given an
actual name so we have to refer to them
using the name of the actor as I have
throughout this entire video this
practice feeds into the hole idolization
of celebrities people are so obsessed
with these actors that they ignore
everything else have you ever referred
to a movie character in conversation not
been able to remember the name and said
something like oh the Jennifer Lawrence
character by not giving any of his
characters names this is exactly the
behavior that Aronofsky is trying to
look up mother on Google right now
you'll notice several articles referring
to the movie as Jennifer Lawrence's new
movie mother as you know by now the film
was directed by Darren Aronofsky not
Jennifer Lawrence
but speaking of Jennifer Lawrence what
an ideal candidate for a movie about the
damage caused by the obsession of
celebrities a few years ago she had her
iCloud hacked and nude photos leaked to
the Internet in an incident known as the
fappening to be entirely transparent
though she may have just been casted
because she's sleeping with the director
literally she is by the way if this
video helps you appreciate the movie a
little bit more go ahead and leave a
like on this video if you are a fan of
psychological horrors go ahead and check
out this nightmare Horror Story video
that I wrote and if you missed
yesterday's dead stream here's a link to
that as well
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]